Boris Johnson may say brexit is now done
but the issue continues to divide
Britain a sky data poll shows BRICS it
remains the top issue of concern for
voters there above health and
immigration although it's worth pointing
out that that figures drop significantly
from almost double that number
pre-election in October to percent now
Boris Johnson's 80 strong majority does
not mean divisions have healed look at
this people do think brexit would be
good for themselves and for the country
but by the narrowest of margins with 37
percent thinking brexit will be good for
them personally and 45 percent saying
will be good for the country nor are the
public yet reassured by what they've
seen of the ongoing negotiation nearly
half the population 48 percent think the
government is doing a bad job in those
talks this includes even the one in six
we voted conservative who don't trust
Boris Johnson's government in the next
phase of the brexit talks and yet for
all of this Boris Johnson is enjoying
something of a honeymoon certainly in
comparison to Labor look at the party
leader approval ratings a whopping 52
percent satisfaction rate for Boris
Johnson even more than that one in 10
people who voted labour in the election
in December seem pleased with the Prime
Minister's performance
now Jeremy Corbyn isn't around for much
longer well late Davi is just the
temporary leader of the Liberal
Democrats and it's not even clear what
if anything the brexit party will become
so despite brexit doubt Boris Johnson is
the biggest beast in the political field
with little insight to challenge him